should Kamala Harris be replaced as Joe
Biden's running mate if indeed he runs
for re-election in 2024 many of you have
been writing to me about this there's
really two big cases to make one on each
side of the question those who say that
yes Kamala Harris should be replaced
with someone else mostly argue that it's
because Kamala Harris is very unpopular
and indeed she is not particularly
popular the argument would be if you
replace Kamala Harris with someone that
maybe is more likable or has higher
approval it would help Joe Biden rather
than be a drag on his re-election ticket
now the Counterpoint is that replacing a
running mate while they are still the
vice president looks very very bad and
indeed it would create some really
awkward conversations